rank these comedians turned podcast HS
from funniest to these funniest Bobby
Lee Andrew Santino Bert ker and Joe
Rogan I'll tell you who's funny and
who's yeah I I don't care I don't care
they know okay as far as uh podcast just
look The Comedians In general ah cuz the
podcast that's easy if I got to rate
them as Comics that's different
wow Bobby Lee Andrew Santino brick ker
Joe
Rogan that's a good man that's a good
man shout out to all those comedians uh
you know to Bert to Andrew to Joe and
and to Bobby Lee uh they've all had me
on their shows and it's it's all been
very beneficial and I always want to
keep it cool so I am eating this for all
four of you
mother whoever wrote these questions man
you're all right